[Music]
the general theme here is money
the way it manifests itself changes from
family to family
sometimes it is people is heirs saying
hey
you're not giving me access to this
trust
or in some cases it is uh family members
who are saying
i should be the one running the company
which kind of starts the feud itself
coke family is worth a hundred billion
dollars
they are the family behind the
conglomerate
coke industries whose products include
pipelines chemicals
and dixie cups you know when people
think about koch brothers
they think about you know david coke and
charles coke but they're actually four
koch brothers
and back in the 80s they had a few of
them amongst themselves where two of the
brothers
wanted to actually be in control of the
family conglomerate
and then they failed and then there was
this back and forth where two of the
brothers charles and david bought up
their other brothers for 700 million
dollars
and then those two brothers bill and
frederick actually came back and they
said
you know what we're shortchanged here we
actually want more money and
they were in litigation uh for a while
so
things like that happen another one
that's kind of crazy
is a feud within the shown family and
they're the family behind u-haul so
husband and wife duo ellis shone and
anna
mary shone they co-founded u-haul
and then ls and his eldest son samuel
they expanded the company and they went
to rentals
of things not just trucks but things
like videotapes and dance floors and jet
skis and when the
expansion happened ellis's other
children joe and mark
they thought that their father was
actually wrecking the company
so they staged a coup in 1986 and
joe joe was the one who staged the coup
and joe took control of the company
and forced his dad out he forced his dad
into retirement
and alienated most of his 12 siblings
and half siblings
and there were lawsuits for 25 years it
got
pretty nasty at one point because ls
even accused his
estranged sons of taking part in the
murder
of samuel's wife in 1990
and they were not guilty a paroled
rapist confessed
and ls told in forbes in 1994
that joe was mentally ill
and the sad part is that ellis himself
died by suicide in 1999
litigations continued for almost 25
years
and the last of litigation concluded in
2012.
there are multiple examples where we
also saw that people
sue their families sometimes they see
their fathers they sue their uncles one
of the examples is the pritzker family
so the prisoner family is a family
behind hyatt hotels
and liza was only 18 years old when she
filed a 6 billion
lawsuit against her father and 11 other
older cousins
she alleged that they looted her and her
brother matthew's trust funds
and her father robert pritzker who was
divorced from
liza's mother irene had begun to tinker
with his
children's trusts and donated their
share in the family holding company to
the family foundation
so years later the cousins are planning
to divvy up the fortune
and they leave lizal and her brother out
and in 2003
uh you know liza says this is not about
the money
she says this is not about the bling
bling it's just you know figuring out
what's the truth
and the battle was over it took some
time and she walked away with 500
million dollars
another case goldman family sol goldman
was the richest landlord in new york
city when he died in 1987.
his properties at one point included the
historic chrysler building
i did not know that you could actually
own the chrysler building but turns out
you can
and shortly after his death soul's four
kids
and his estranged wife lillian began
battling over
the inheritance when you go to court
it's because you
couldn't resolve a dispute amongst
yourselves
so i think that's why we don't really
see a lot of new people fighting right
now because if they're fighting maybe
they haven't taken it to court
so that's why a lot of established
families appear with their disputes
because
these litigations are stories that
they've taken over
decades i think going forward uh we'll
definitely be seeing
more of these stories for sure and also
i'm sure there's a lot of feuding that
happens that doesn't go
to court that you know we would not
really have visibility into
you